hello there and welcome to this
delicious slice of Internet so Dan how's
it going yeah good have a good time yeah
I've always wanted to film a cannon in
slow-mo me too
luckily people have Captain Morgan white
rum I provided this with this nice
cannon here and some some drinks thanks
Captain Morgan white rum
we appreciate the cannon so we've got we
got cannon and a load of sort of odd
looking drinks to fire at get some
aiming on the go
can't miss these drinks how would you
rate your cannon aiming skills top
pretty tall tower top yeah top of the
line I ever missed with a cannon before
so it's gonna go like this I'd be well
annoyed if you're not those down right
now so I'm gonna film this on the fan of
flex two-and-a-half thousand frames
which is hundred times slower than your
eyeball and uh hopefully it'll look a
bit gnarly not a bad shot
yeah pretty good GoPro survived beat
this point I missed like three of them
there's the ball down here flood
obliterate it
oh there it comes
wallop oh look at that annihilate it it
really just didn't care about the glass
it's just like what straight I can
imagine the cannonball like looking back
like what was that
so while we'll get in additional angles
do not explain what you did
well we were using the GoPro to try and
get a good shot of this sort of
cannonball cone passed yeah I'll cut to
the footage of that right now
oh wait my god because you absolutely
mullet it I'm sorry
nothing nothing left look at the bloody
memory card holes every stick gun that's
just felt like the salvageable snow
there's no date on it yeah you blew the
date around my memory card it's your
direct hit yeah success now was a lot of
fun it was really good that you
absolutely mode those drinks
yeah perfect straight line through good
aim that was good fun I think I'll take
one of these back with me actually it's
a kit well we actually made two other
videos for the captain morbid youtube
channel so you can click those links
here there on the screen give those a
click check them out subscribe to us
subscribe to them follow us on Twitter
all that go for it
you